have seen this video online it is
everywhere recently the Oxford Union the
debating site Society in Oxford England
held a debate on wokeness and from out
of nowhere a podcast hosting comedian
called Constantine Kissin defied the
odds and won over the audience on a
college campus with force and Brilliance
if you're wondering how he did it here's
how
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions which
means that if Britain was to sink into
the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give about
saving the planet
120 million people in China do not have
enough food
I don't mean that they don't get dessert
I mean they suffer from malnutrition
that means that their immune system is
breaking down because they don't have
enough food
you're not going to get them to stay
poor and the only thing that wokeness
has to offer in exchange is to brainwash
Bright Young Minds like you to believe
that you are victims to believe that you
have no agency to believe that what you
must do to improve the world is to
complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings we know that the way to
improve the world is to work is to
create it is to build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours to forget about that
well you'll notice if you watch that
video that he's not reading that there's
no teleprompter he's ad-libbing that
whole thing that is right off the top of
his head
that's not easy
constant kissing is the co-host of the
trigonometry podcast he joins us tonight
we sure appreciate your coming on I
think the video of your remarks at the
Oxford Union has been shared more than
you know anything on social media in the
US in a long time how how was the
response to what you said
it was great but I think people really
enjoyed it and I think it's partly
because people are fed up of worknesses
of course you know but I think also
there's another thing going on Tucker we
live in a society in which adults are
afraid of children and young people in
particular and so when you see somebody
who is an adult talking to young people
and being straight with them and saying
look if you care about certain issues in
the world if you care about climate
change or racial Injustice or whatever
whining and complaining is not going to
fix that problem that we need young
people to step up and actually work and
build and create things and as I said in
the speech to to create the technology
and the science that is going to help
solve all the problems of the future so
I think that's one of the reasons it's
gone so viral and the feedback has been
incredible I really haven't received any
negative feedback at all it's been very
very positive so I'm very grateful for
that well we're grateful to see it
because I mean first of all you made a
rational fact-based case which is always
assuring to see it's wonderful to see
someone making an argument and you did
but it's the first time in a long time
I've ever I've seen somebody directly
challenge the prevailing view on campus
and not get shouted down how did that
happen
well as you say I think I made a
rational argument and I think this is
the thing that I've been thinking about
a lot you know we spoke a few years ago
and as a comedian I was concerned about
the erosion of free speech and the
censorship particularly in this country
in the UK but as we've interviewed
people in trigonometry as we've spoken
to some of the greatest Minds you know
the Jordan Petersons of the world and
many others what I've started to realize
is that this ideology workness is
fundamentally anti-human and the
narrative goes something like this you
know we are evil particularly westerners
especially you know straight white men
like you but actually all of us are evil
and we must be punished and that's why
some of the solutions that we're being
offered to the issue of climate change
don't seem to make much sense I don't
really see how making pensioners in
Britain freeze to death over the winter
is going to solve the problem of climate
change or indeed impoverishing people in
India in China and I think actually
we've got to believe that young people
are persuadable we've got to make
rational arguments to them and that is I
think the way to deal with many of these
problems we've got to challenge young
people to step up and be better
we have to believe that young people are
persuadable and I think a lot of us in
the elderly Community or near elderly
are losing confidence in that
um but you believe it to be true having
just had this experience
I do and I think we all have to embrace
that approach I think we're not going to
get anywhere by chastising people we
have to try and persuade them I think
that you've we've got to remember Tucker
the young minds we were all young once
and we were just as idiotic and stubborn
and so sure of ourselves that we thought
we knew everything I think we've got to
fight we've got to fight to change
people's minds and the way to do that is
a rational argument and encouraging
critical thinking which is what I hope
my speech has done yes I remember as a
young man I was very impressed by and
persuaded by people who had forceful
ideas they could clearly and rationally
Express and I'm glad to see there's
still people like that because you you
did that Constantine thank you so much
[Music]